un giro dramático en un caso de alto
perfil el príncipe andrew de reino unido
llegó este martes a un acuerdo
extrajudicial en su caso civil por
presunta agresión sexual con su
acusadora virginia giuffré en una carta
emitida por sus abogados se lee que el
segundo hijo de la reina pagará una suma
de dinero no revelada y que elogia la
valentía de joffré el palacio de
buckingham por su parte se ha negado a
comentar al respecto
el príncipe andrew pretende hacer una
donación sustancial a la organización
benéfica de la señorita hefner en apoyo
de los derechos de las víctimas el
príncipe andrew nunca tuvo en la
intención de difamar a la señorita sufre
y reconoce que ya ha sufrido tanto como
víctima establecida de abuso así como
por ataques públicos injustos la
relación del príncipe con el difunto
delincuente sexual con victoria epstein
y su socia sisley maxwell también estaba
bajo la lupa en el caso se acusaba el
duque de york de abusar sexualmente de
joffré tres veces cuando ya tenía 17
años mientras estaba siendo traficadas
por existen acusaciones que él ha
desmentido en repetidas ocasiones en una
entrevista con la bbc en 2019 el
príncipe fue criticado por negar
rotundamente conocer a jeffrey y dijo
que el relato del encuentro hecho por
ella no es cierto porque él es incapaz
de sudar
creo que les va a costar mucho
recuperarse de un golpe como esté todo
el caso del príncipe andrew año aún más
la reputación de todos
la gente probablemente aún respeta a la
reina pero no creo que a andrew
si bien and you no ha sido formalmente
acusado si ha caído en desgracia al ser
despojado de todos sus patrocinios
reales y afiliaciones militares y perder
su título real en una capacidad oficial
maxwell la exnovia de epstein fue
sentenciada a finales del año pasado por
cinco cargos federales incluido el de
tráfico sexual